hey David there's a lot of discussion
about taxing the very rich at 70% or
higher where specifically would you set
the 70 percent tax bracket to begin okay
very good question when we talk about
higher marginal tax rates we're not
talking about for example when we say
the top rate should be 70 percent we're
not saying you take rich people and you
tax them 70 percent on all of their
income we are saying income above a
certain threshold is taxed at 70 percent
so you might if imagine we set the 70
percent marginal rate at 10 million
dollars you would pay thirty six percent
federally or whatever it is on your
first four at four hundred thousand five
hundred thousand dollars in income we
might establish a forty two percent rate
on income between five hundred thousand
and one point five million between one
point five million and ten million you
might pay fifty five percent and then on
that income above ten million you would
start to pay the seventy percent
marginal tax rate I have seen good plans
good proposals that would start the 70
percent rate at five million ten million
and twenty million now you might say
David you could make eighteen million
dollars and not pay the top rate that
seems insane that seems like an
incredible continued handout to the very
rich and in a sense it is but what you
have to understand is that the very very
wealthy are often not earning income via
wages they're earning income via
investments and business distributions
and those are depending on how they're
set up not taxed at the income tax rate
so you could have someone who earns a
salary of five hundred thousand dollars
and then that is subject to income tax
on wages and then they might get twenty
million dollars through other mechanisms
where it's only subject to the capital
gains tax so that's why if we're really
going to have a serious conversation
about deciding that as a country as a
society the very rich have to pay more
you're going to have to deal with
capital gains because as has been
pointed out before the
marginal tax rate alone doesn't dictate
effective levels of taxation and what I
mean by effective is not that they work
well I mean actual so like what is the
actual effective tax rate that you're
paying you're going to have to deal with
capital gains for those very very rich
people but I want to then go even
further with this for a moment it's
really important not to allow the
super-rich to control the narrative on
this issue because in every way the
language that's used to discuss this
topic the language that's used to
discuss a lot of related topics that are
important to how much money are the
plutocrats and the corporations and the
kleptocrats going to end up with the
language and the discourse is
deliberately narrowed in a way that
systemic lis favors the rich so the
focus needs to be initially it's not
about the top 20% although the top 20%
is important but the top 20% includes
people who are making a lot less than
you might imagine it's not even about
the top 10% it's not even about the top
5% the level of inequality between the
top 0.1% the top point five percent and
the top 1% is enormous
and what we have to remember when we
think about levels of Taxation is that
this is not about although we should
have this conversation it's not about
drastically increasing the taxes paid by
someone who makes 421 thousand dollars a
year which puts them at the very bottom
of the top one percent this is about the
top point five percent the top point one
percent and the top point oh one percent
and if you're going to deal with that
seriously just taxing earned income
wages is not going to be the way to do
it but I've sort of gone on a complete
tangent I've seen reasonable plans where
the top rate kicks in at five ten or 20
million and I am sort of leaning towards
the five or ten million is the place
where I would have that kick in let me
know what you think let me know about
your ideas regarding tax brackets and
capital gains and what else needs to
happen we've got a great great
his show for you today become a member
at WWN pakman.com or become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show to
get instant access to the world-famous
bonus show